波空ける小穴をしていて1ルマンド子はいーな実感を得て早9年約9年くらいまともに
実家で飯を食っていません肇社長です皆さんが気になってるかわかんないんですけど僕
は気になっています弾み節夫
2020年夏季んどれくらいしたーー
はいこの前ですね俺の無駄市の動画で今までの僕の課金額っていうのを見に来たんです
けども
去年分の課金組てないんですよ
僕はちょっと本当にエアワーナーソナーなんであのアプリの課金
悪いとは言わんですけどもや遺跡は本当によくないんですよねほんとバーンで10万円
くらい課金したときに何もをはなくなった時もあったりして俺このままだとマジでクズ
人間になりそうだなと思って自分の戒めのためにも去年どれくらい自分使ったんだろう
なっていうのをちょっと見ていこうと思いますあの
おっ
引かないでくださいえっ
ない時は早速 apple id 見ていきましょう2020年は579回確認して
おります前年の2019年に比べてちょっと減ったかな
いや結構入ったら100君20回ぐらい120回ぐらい課金の排出が少なくなってまた
これ言い方とかもしれません
さっそく見ていきましょう7月と10月が84回95回3つが気にするなんて
1月から入っていきますはい1月1日からですまずいけないパズドラですねだかお正月
場所に行きたかったのかな
1月1日からいきなり¥7,460ぶっこんでますやったな俺までお正月ってさ何か
良いガチャが多いけど全然これはアリだと思うんですけども姉まだ1月1日が続いてる
ぞ
モンストとパズドラは違うわけわからないピアノ本にもお金が取られてますね
細い
1万円分今でパズドラもちょっとだけ買ってます1番星のべきの2公演1月12日また
かピアノベースやばくねこれめっちゃ1100前に取られてたんだけど解約したいんだ
けどやり方わかんないんですね月プロスターパズドラに課金してますねはブロサー
6,100円も混んでます
9,190円うわなら1月の中旬はめちゃくちゃなブロスターに確認してますね
モーターファーム
あってますね1月の24ブローさに抹茶6102でてキングにハマった時期ですね
ちょっと曲を買ったりします10,970円1月の283,300円めっちゃ捉えて
こんなが1週間に1回黒ピアノ農家で採れたねこれ
あ字開脚して最後1型の31日に3358払うバードラグくのドライバーゼファーや
tribe 2をしたかったんでしょうねはいこんな感じですねえっと1月の換金額は
5万8000671円
まあ抑えた方でしょいや間違えてる普通の人からすると5万はやばいってのはわかっ
てるんですけど俺的にはかなり抑えた方だと思いますよ
それで2月です2月も最初から質問にが3発泥で3,780円かましてゆくまた午前中
は誕生日前田2月の12日に突然すげーもんとに課金し始めてますここでき
14,900円さーちゃん
装備2月の中4日金が止まりませんモンスターとだけ市米本散策1枚モンスター空研一
枚モンスターされちまえもんだ目で追って菅谷倍も止まらん
ああもう間近俺ちょっとまだでヤバイぞワーママチャリが降りて踊って大丈夫か俺
やばいと課金焼けたがいまだでこれまだねぇ俺大丈夫か
鍛造に通した俺
上まってっ
ごめんお母さん経てば強いもう山であれ
あレイプ魔てもう食べ放題もうダメやばいまじやばい待って待ってるって思ってうわー
うわーうわーうわー
まず様なかったとママをもうやめをもうああもうダメだもうこれやばいバァーン
で来ればばーかってないよね俺全員にされと死んだよ待ってよこれ本当に大丈夫
あっえっと止まりましたヤバいじゃバイこれはやばいと
ハッキングされとるんか数えません2月8日12
ん
454647ザーツ48万課金してネットへ
またまた俺なんかしたってた蔓に a 今年やばい
まずはちょっとまたパズラーなんかパズドラと思うと一気ですね本当に
あーた皿鳥が来たらやばいやばいやばいハイツ後半家族しました英雄入学の課金額で
55万1790円ネスもポンコツですねを
谷田部ても誕生日プレゼントみたいな感覚だったんだろうなぁ1か月で55万書するっ
て俺
やるや砂丘が不安ですけどまぁ誕生日月だったねまま許してください次行きましょう3
月です
いやー3月もそんなの1日も予選ですね
ただ課金回数は少なかったですね比較的3差3月
archi なきゃいけるまた来てれ俺
急にこうや高度に課金してるはいはいこんな感じですね
いや抑えた方だな三方五月の課金額167000470円です完全にはめが外れてます
ね10万超えたら結構ちょっとも問題だと思っていいと思うは4月見ていきます脚月
ですね4月のモーモンととかパズドラとかそんな感じでカーって買ってますね
いやー活動買いすぎだなああなるほど
落ち着いてるな4月の剛撃ん8番2340円です
on
8番ですか感じると5月見ていきますうわぁ屋根を冠するなこれが艶やかするねこれ
これじゃないですこれじゃないですよ
ドラゴンボールで1回始まりますこれ誰なんだかまた歯止めが効かなくなっている
そしてここで何か急にまた中10人靴にハマってますね
ああっがついちゃってねこれが釣れちゃってねこれ阿呆がっつり入っちゃってねこれ
阿呆ガッツれちゃってね
あもうだめだーらーはぁ
ああ
アート5月28万3040円です
これやばいな俺病気あんあの集計まずしっかりしていくんでちぷちこみがんばりますで
は
温菜抑えている最低のされている6月12万6千と崩れです7月なんでもっと少ない
ところ多分
af キャリイなってアプリにハマってしまいましてあれと勢山史上最強レベルで課金
してダンスみてくださいこれ
呼吸をセラー2 f キャリアにかけしております
ただ本当たら前多分イヤイヤ期が来ておりカイザーどこ一番2000と言っちゃってる
のはこれもたぶんやばいです癒さ7月ちょっとお楽しみにすごいんで
デイケアリーダーの地獄を見てますやばい吐きダコねまぁそしてモンスト
多い組のモンスト
止まらない止まらない聞いてもらったかと思います1 a
ケアリーなってゲームやはすぎてこんなに課金すればか気にするほど強くなるんですよ
どれネバーワールドのランキングがトップファイルとか良いと動いデー
止まんなくなったってどうじゃなかったですね7月の課金額
これ本当ですロック107,730円です
やばいってー今年やばいぞんちょっと切れの声もこの先
8月でしょうもういい加減たらされてたと思うんですよね左なんでさぁモンスト金8月
はもう貞勝や桜持つだねもう一手はここもまだ fd アリーナだなぁか通学のため
やばいと思います見ていきましょう
いやーもう誰だちょっとやばいは8型の課金額43万1460円です
今年はすごい外に行くんだかお金怒ってに使ってると思えばぜってー
大したことあるさあ9月でていきましょう2020年9月結構続いてるじゃんこれ
ひいてはないかな275009167印です
さあ次は問題です監禁回数95回2020年10月でちょっと重圧のやつパプ皆さんの
声を見てください
この多分モンストですねうん局長として団からも多分もう人が止まっ
ないんですよ課金が高給をするに1万円で限りません
数えていきましたはい
サシェ休憩方が20輪曲かけしますねある旧どころじゃないか
休憩処じゃないああいやお前バーン
なにゃんでどさくさに紛れてもめっちゃ
妄想にもできました
[音楽]
ij 2010年10月課金額
ほとんどモンストでしたまんで
50円です
[音楽]
これマジでやばいなぁ多分でこの10月が max ですねちょっと11月12月
バット計算して最後2020年の合計金額出そうと思いますし場所まちょ
[音楽]
お家811月が20万3,219円ですえっとね幻神が課金と根暗側にもちょっと書に
しましたね
原子にめっちゃ気にせたな12月はネタめちゃくちゃ少ないと思うんだと12月が
落ち着いています
115,80060ご縁でございます
あ
いいというわけで2020年の集計終わりました一枚付けて確実な金額だしたんでまぁ
これ全部貢献していきたいとおもいます
もうやばい詰まった入ってるも70万を超えてる時点で問題が嫌な予感しかしないん
じゃない1月が5万8600ならスイッチん
ああああああああ
ん
日本
じゃじゃあもう1級出せてくださいちょっと不安ですね
を完璧に行ってました2020で始めたというのを使ったアプリすべての課金額の結果
は
364万3,366円でした
2019年測ってないんですけども2018年が219万円鍵してたんだ
ではそっから比べると思う300万300300万後半まで来たということですね
2019年どうだったんだろう
2010金の課金が本当に気になっちゃって合計じゃあしたところ
カチカチカチカチ火事の k さんちゃんとして計算したところ衝撃の事実がわかり
ましたその
2019の
た金額はなんと2020年度桔梗100257237 in 深く最後条約
257237員でした
おうち時間ということでやっぱりスマホとカーで遊ぶ時が多かったねまぁ致し方ない
出費だと思います
[音楽]
pou dou dou
あっちょ